thank you so much for joining us for
afghanistan's future development the
state and the humanitarian challenge
this is the 11th in the series the l
development dialogues which are virtual
panel discussions hosted by yale's
economic growth center jackson institute
for global affairs and history
department i'm catherine chaney i'm a
senior reporter at devex focused on
technology and innovation and global
development and i'm thrilled to moderate
this series the yale development
dialogues for those of you who aren't
familiar brings together perspectives
from history economics and policy to
discuss ways to address challenges
facing low and middle-income countries
and today we're joined by experts who
have been at the forefront of policy in
afghanistan over the past two decades
so i have a number of questions i'd like
to ask them but for those of you joining
us here live on the zoom webinar we
really encourage you to submit your
questions via the q a function so keep
those coming throughout and i'll get to
them as soon as i can
so transitioning to the topic we're
discussing today
the american withdrawal from afghanistan
left the international community
uncertain not only in terms of the
future of the country and its people
women and girls in particular but also
the future of intervention
so today we'll be asking questions like
how does the situation in afghanistan
fit into a history of many failed and
some productive interventions
what should the priorities of the
international development community be
as they interact with the country now
especially as the country faces a real
humanitarian crisis
and what does the future hold for the
reconstruction of afghanistan and its
relationship with the same foreign
powers who were previously invaders
so joining us to discuss these questions
and more we're thrilled to be joined by
dr ozala nemat an afghan scholar and
think tank leader who is research
associate at the department of
development studies which is part of the
school of oriental and african studies
in the uk
khaleda who served as the last minister
of finance in the islamic republic of
afghanistan leading an ambitious
portfolio of economic reforms and
anti-corruption initiatives until his
resignation in august 2021
and rory stewart senior fellow at yale's
jackson institute for global affairs who
served as the uk secretary of state for
international development his work
focuses on contemporary politics in
crisis and on international development
and intervention in fragile and
conflict-affected states and he's
written extensively on afghanistan
rory is also co-organizer of this event
the yale development dialogue series
um and he spent a lot of time in
afghanistan from his solo walk across
the country in 2002 to his work starting
and running the turquoise mountain
foundation to his role uh in government
in the uk
and rory i know you've been involved in
a number of conversations on afghanistan
recently i've reviewed many of them in
preparation for this discussion so i
mentioned earlier the yell development
dialogues is unique in terms of the
interdisciplinary perspectives we bring
together so i'd love to hear what are
some of your thoughts and goals for this
particular conversation what can our
audience expect
thank you very very much indeed and it's
it's great to be here and and a great
privilege to be with my two afghan
colleagues um who i hope we're going to
be doing the majority of the talking
let me just try to frame it slightly
from a yale university point of view
in the history of international
development so
afghanistan is both a very exceptional
situation but also one that connects to
a much much broader
longer history
so
in terms of exception
people will think about it as a military
intervention but it was also one of the
largest
development international developments
in humanitarian exercises of the last 20
years
this was a country in which the
international community didn't only
deploy
nearly a million military personnel over
the period but hundreds of thousands of
civilians
who worked with afghan partners on
almost every dimension of economic
development
on human rights on civil society on
schooling on health
with absolutely unparalleled levels of
investment now as with any of these
situations
it is possible to criticize a lot of
that investment of course
much of the money which was spent by the
international community in afghanistan
ended up finding its way back to the
west
through strange contracts there was also
of course a lot of corruption
nevertheless there are very very few
countries in the world over the last 20
years where quite so much was invested
and there was a very very ambitious idea
on remodeling a society
so it gives us an opportunity to see
what with all the ideas of the west or
the technology of the west or the money
of the west what was was not achieved
over a 20-year period and how that
compares to the way we thought about
international development from the 1950s
onwards
and now of course we find ourselves in a
new challenge which is the taliban
government has taken over
people are trying to put pressure on the
taliban government and use development
and humanitarian assistance as leverage
potentially over the taliban government
at a time when there is an extreme
humanitarian crisis and afghans are now
facing starvation in some parts of the
country
so it then raises a second series of
questions on the way in which we think
about international development in the
future
so on that i'm i'm going to step aside
for a bit um and maybe hand back to my
afghan colleagues to speak thank you
thank you rory and i apologize for some
background noise unavoidable background
noise on my end here that will hopefully
subside shortly um but one of the things
that khaled mentioned in preparation for
this call was the importance of
beginning our conversation with what was
achieved while we're tasked with talking
about the future it is important to
highlight what the 20-year intervention
achieved so i wonder if you could expand
on that on that
and thank you very much it's a
privilege to be to be happy greetings to
you to the esteemed panelists and also
the moderator and and the participants
who have joined us online
uh i wouldn't spend a lot of time i
think we've already beautifully covered
a part of it you know unprecedented
amount of it flowing into a country but
it also achieved a lot
and the wake of the tragedy that we've
seen
over the last 90 days it's difficult
it's
difficult to to to get a perspective of
20 years but a lot was achieved you know
going from a
uh
gdp per capita of below 200 dollars to
tripling it over
the first decade and a half
having nine million children go back to
school you know more than uh 30 35 of
them
girls
uh of improvements on other social
economic uh indicators you know
plummeting
maternal mortality numbers which were
the worst in the world
building institutions that were still
people complaining about but
providing some service deliveries you
know people
making uh a nine ten hour trip all the
way to the border to pakistan just to
make a call to a relative in the us or
and and
and the west could now have
social media and
telecommunication you know and mobile at
their finger
tips
afghanistan connected with multiple
flights a day
flying out out of kabul a lot of key
infrastructure
built that enabled integration of the
country better but also
enabled better
regional connectivity had it been for
better
relationships with the with the
neighbors that
key infrastructure could have done even
much more so a lot was achieved that's
obviously with the amount of money
flowing with little uh
accountability with systems that were to
be built obviously there were misuse and
was sometimes unfortunately with good
intentions wastages that could have been
abided
but a lot was achieved i say this and i
wanted uh for us to start with because
in 2001 we
faced a similar situation i think it's
uh it's an incredibly incredibly
difficult people for the whole nation
and nation
but uh keeping a long-term perspective
helps you know
having the faith and that things could
could be better
i'll stop here absolutely no i
appreciate you
um
you know starting us off with that that
important perspective and zooming in on
one example of progress uh ursala i know
you have over two decades of experience
in development practice and promoting
women's rights in more affected
societies so i wonder if you can expand
on the gains for afghan women and girls
over the past two decades
and then we can talk about where we are
now
thank you
thank you very much catherine um it's a
great honor and pleasure to be part of
this distinguished panel and uh
joining uh rory and uh hollywood and
yourself into this discussion very
crucial and timely i would say
um with regards to uh gains of the last
20 years
uh before even starting to talk about
days we have to sort of
keep in mind that the games come with a
lot of topics as well
uh
uh generally speaking and specifically
with regards to women so i just sort of
divide the gains in terms of social
political politically not
and very briefly front of all of it just
for us for our sort of memories to
remind ourselves of what has been the
changes
in the social fields uh what we see
have been achieved is uh
massive
and
excuse me there was an annoying sound i
hope you now don't hear it my notebook
was going somewhere
i hope now it's clearer
um so in terms of social gains what i'm
like what i'd like to highlight is this
change in people particularly generally
in afghanistan and rural afghanistan in
terms of
people's behaviors towards women's
rights women's position in the society
there has been some unprecedented level
of
achievements in the rural and community
development side of things
in some communities and in some areas
that i have gone because of my own
research on local power relations and
local governance i find out that for the
first time in the history of these areas
the state and the donors have reached
there not to extract but to deliver
so this is something that we cannot deny
nobody including the taliban cannot deny
the the impact of the community
development and the role of women in the
community development programs
the conditionality that was set up has
been a game changer now
having said that in terms of social
behavioral change has happened
we see
a thirst for education we see that
thirst for education across the country
across generations across gender
there is a pin pad campaign by
volunteers from the southern afghanistan
running around
with the men that in appearance to all
internationals look like a taliban no
different from a tall one long beard big
turban having this
uh a paper
a placard in their hand and says open
the schools for girls so that's
something that has a message for
everyone particularly for those who are
ruling the country now the political
gains although in many aspects quite
symbolic but has been also important we
have had in the constitution 25 percent
quotas
but
a lot of women made it beyond that quota
in the provincial and provincial council
and parliamentary elections
so the symbolic part aside in the
political reason some of the behaviors
of the politicians using instrumentally
women position was there but women
themselves have created an identity for
for themselves to be very particular
not necessarily representing themselves
as the representatives of the western
values or eastern values or anything
very very pure very traditional but at
the same time very aware and conscious
of their rights i think these are
critical and just very quickly i know
i've gone beyond my two minutes but just
very quickly in terms of economic gains
as well
in the we have to remember 70 percent of
afghan population lives in rural areas
but the economic gains has also been
quite significant in the rural context
where women were able to access market
sell their products to the level
possible obviously and i'm just worried
what will happen to it now women were
able to make to be involved in
businesses small medium and larger
scales more in the small and medium
range
less in the larger because of of course
the men are trying to sort of
maneuver more over them so overall in
all these different
sort of
areas there has been quite significant
gains that we cannot deny it and that's
something
that with the crisis that is happening
now
may be affected maybe we will see the
different levels and maybe we'll see
some changes but there will not be a
kind of a dragging to the zero point
again that's my sort of bit of an
optimism optimism in terms of moving uh
way forward thanks thank you rory please
jump in a couple of quick things i mean
i think the first thing to understand is
that the
story in afghanistan is uneven depending
upon which part of the country you're
talking about so in many ways there was
huge progress not not just in urban
areas obviously in places that the
cities but
also in places like the bamiyan valley
hazard extraordinary transformation over
20 years other areas of the country for
example the sangeen district in helmand
very very difficult
and in some ways the lives of women in
those communities didn't change as much
as we would have liked over the period
partly because they were in the middle
of a horrible conflict drug wars
warlords and ultimately a taliban
insurgency
on the second point that dr orzada has
made about small businesses this is
absolutely vital and there's actually a
great deal the international community
can do to help
at the moment there are nearly a million
afghan women working in the carpet
industry
and that industry has amazing potential
you don't need to think about it as it
might have been of the past as a place
which was dominated by minimum wages and
child labor
we were beginning uh in the last couple
of years to secure some very high value
contracts for afghan carpets selling to
big american and european
buyers and suppliers
setting up good weaving workshops with
good conditions for children and crashes
and actually as turkey and india moves
out of the handmade carpet industry that
could be a huge
uh opportunity
for afghans to generate small and
medium-sized enterprises the problem is
that the international community now
is not putting any more investment usaid
said it's not going to support the
export industry anymore
everybody's saying we're just going to
think about humanitarian support and
this is classified as development
support and this will mean very
unnecessarily and cruelly that these
great export opportunities these
contracts that women have managed to
secure with huge difficulty
are now under threat from the
international community itself
often for quite unconvincing reasons to
do with uh
unrealistic views of how they can
leverage the taliban
i think that's a great example when it
comes to uh questions we'll get to
around the role the international
development community in afghanistan
some of the decisions being made are are
hampering some potential progress here
um for example in the carpet industry
really interesting um i wanted to
talk about
um the withdrawal and certainly make
sure we talk about that before we
look at the current state of the country
in the future um so you know as i
mentioned earlier
the dramatic collapse of the military
and takeover by the taliban really left
the international community uncertain
about not just the future of the country
but the future of intervention and rory
i know as you and i discussed the
framing of this event um we wanted to
talk not just about afghanistan and its
future which is our main task but also
how this fits into a history of
interventions and and that speaks to the
spirit of the all development dialogues
weaving in history so um can you expand
on that just kind of putting this into
larger historical context and then i'd
love to see if our other panelists have
additional thoughts
yeah so
essentially afghanistan
was the last big intervention
in a 20-year period of intervention
which started with bosnia and kosovo
which actually gave quite a lot of
confidence to the international
community because in bosnia and kosovo
essentially there was an intervention it
was largely peaceful a war ended there
was no insurgency and progress was made
and that in a sense drove some of the uh
investment into iraq and afghanistan
which of course were the two later
interventions
in the case of afghanistan itself there
were three distinct phases there was an
initial phase of quite a light footprint
very few troops not doing very much
then the international community got
dragged into doing more and more and
more because they felt that the
situation in 2001 2005 was not
satisfactory
and then they went back to a light
footprint again
the the issue however is that the lesson
that will be taken from afghanistan is
not actually the points that
aled or dr ozil have made about how much
was achieved in the united states and in
europe unfortunately
people are convincing themselves that
nothing was achieved
that the whole thing was a mess and i
think probably the
which is completely not true
i mean for any of us who saw afghanistan
at the end of the taliban period the
difference between then
and 2021 was unbelievable i mean kabul
was a ghost town at the end of 2001
there was you know i when i walked from
iraq to kabul there was no electricity
for 350 miles in 2001 i mean it's a
totally different country
but
uh we need to start
rebuilding some confidence amongst the
international community that something
can be achieved
and it's about getting out of a black
and white mindset of course we've proved
that you can't build a perfect nation
under fire
but that doesn't mean that you can't do
anything that doesn't mean that the
whole project of international
development is a waste of time or
there's nothing that you can do of
course there's corruption there's waste
right
but i think uh
really put his finger on it
in putting that in context explain yes
those things happen
they don't just happen in afghanistan
they happened in sub-saharan africa
they happened in myanmar they have known
many places
and things can go wrong
but when things go wrong when the
taliban takes over don't conclude from
that
that that is because all afghans want to
taliban government that's the other
mistake that people are making the
taliban didn't come into these towns
with everybody waving flags saying
welcome the taliban
this is an armed jihadist group they
were not elected
and afghan's been fighting for 20 years
and ultimately
people chose not to
commit suicide trying to fight the
taliban but that doesn't mean that
they've chosen the taliban
and that doesn't mean that afghans as a
whole think that the last 20 years was a
waste of time and they prefer the
situation they have at the moment
absolutely khalid or salah you want to
jump in on that
um
yeah i second everything rory state
including as as last intervention on on
the
the differences in how intervention was
done within provinces you know it also
had to do a lot with winning hearts and
minds
somehow military did not do what
militaries do you know they went and
created parallel structures dwarfing
their uh
other institutions that were supposed to
do aid work you know u.s military
spending
and some years 100 times more in on
development than usa this is going to
uh skew the whole the whole um
development agenda and and unfortunately
you know the the
the size of the national budget was so
small and so much was spent outside the
budget that
the government had a real problem you
know
showing
uh and increasing its legitimacy you
know so these these things
really did did have a have a role in how
thing things uh played and unfortunately
you know when
when you look at some of the lessons
that come out of afghanistan it's not
the first time you know if you look at
aid effectiveness principles of what you
should do and don't and how you spend
and what channels you use
and how the government could be a
partner
unfortunately
not much has been learned and there is a
lot of lessons
that are reiterated from afghanistan
that should be learned and but then i'm
i'm not very optimistic about the
behavior of these international
institutions and and learning those
those lessons from afghanistan uh
for uh hopefully you know improved
intervention in afghanistan from now on
or somewhere else
or zala anything to add in terms of uh
lessons that should have been learned to
inform um
you know
yes it had lessons from history been
considered perhaps um things would have
unfolded differently
and or lessons that we should be taking
now from
um you know the crisis that has unfolded
to inform work moving forward
thank you catherine
that have been mentioned i think
afghanistan
in terms of
many
fields whether international relations
or even
many other economics whatever
particularly including i would say
development studies field i think it's a
case study
in all different ways um so uh in that
sense my hope and desire is to see all
you know uh educational institutions
globally across the world in this
developing world but also in the
developed world
they have to pick afghanistan and study
each and every project in program
interventions
and there is a tremendous amount of
lessons to be learned in all of it
i'll go about some general lessons
learned because i'm sure you know yale
and the politics department and
everything can get it sort of to hire i
think one of the biggest lessons that
the
intervening forces need to learn is to
stop investing on individuals
we started with making karzai
the most well-dressed man of the year
and we ended up with what we're calling
him
i don't know all kind of
a man with all kind of illnesses and
schizophrenic or whatever
we started ashraf ghani with calling him
the
second thoughtful man i don't know
marzon [ __ ] how to translate
that back into english but theorist in
chief i looked
looked up and googled you know he was
second second neverest man in the world
we said
something like that right so we call him
the new york the new york uh
uh new yorker actually call him the
theorist in chief
and then look at what happened right so
stop
investing on individuals when you
intervene in a country it will end up in
a disaster as it did
the other biggest lesson i think to very
go very broadly is the issue of donor
dependency
the starvation that ruri was mentioning
before
this situation the catastrophe that we
are facing now it's quite shocking in
fact if you think about it one in two
people don't know when the where the
next food is coming from and i i
literally witnessed that on daily basis
dealing with my own uh
friends and relatives and colleagues
this is the depth of the the crisis
you cannot put this all on a government
or a failed government or one one party
i think from the united nations to to
world bank to all the donor conferences
and fancy you know reports and
everything everyone should question
themselves why we led everything to this
level of dependency
and
last but not least one other part that i
would like to go on is
aggressive means
always fail
the whole of war on terror was a failure
we have to note that
the whole mission was to go
and smoke out quote unquote
the the terrorists
guess what
those you call terrorists are
handed over back the whole country to on
we don't go into blaming a game here but
aggressive means guantanamo bay drone
attacks nitrates didn't work and that's
what we see the taliban are more
aggressive today because of those they
are reacting against their actions that
were taken against them so i think these
are key
lessons that we need to sort of look
into
stopping here all right go ahead
one thing i would add is the
international community being modest and
humble
with itself and with others about what
it can achieve one of one of the
problems is that when you're spending
and i when i was sexually state for
international development i felt this
pressure you're spending billions of
dollars in somebody else's country so
there's a lot of pressure to tell the
voters in europe or the united states
that we're going to transform everything
and you also are always showing off
towards afghans telling them it's all
going to be great we know what we're
doing we have best practice capacity
building it's all going to be amazing
it would be very helpful to from the
beginning set more realistic
expectations
the truth is the history of
international development in a country
with a lot of challenges like
afghanistan and as
as harlot has pointed out this was one
of the poorest countries in the world in
2001.
with a situation where many villages in
2001 there was only maybe one or two
people in the whole village who could
read or write
right
and it's almost impossible to know what
the
infant mortality rate was because there
was no proper registration of births and
deaths under the taliban but we know it
was terrible
so if you're starting from that level to
be very realistic with afghanistan with
your own voters about what you can
achieve
so instead of saying we're going to
create and this is something we all did
british politicians did it but afghan
politicians did it too you know ashraf
ghani i remember
when i saw him at the beginning of 2002
saying we're going to create a
gender-sensitive multi-ethnic
centralized state based on democracy
human rights rule of law
it's not very helpful
of course maybe that's the long-term aim
but begin by saying our aim is
over 10 or 20 years to make afghanistan
more prosperous
improve the schools improve the clinics
it's going to be slow it's going to take
a lot of time and by building that
spirit
you're not going to get so many
frustrated afghans you're not going to
get frustrated voters you're not going
to get into this crazy
very american all-or-nothing mentality
you know either we
throw the entire u.s military at it or
we do nothing at all
right
this doesn't work domestically if you
were working with a
i don't know a a
community in the united states with high
unemployment let's say a coal community
in east kentucky
you wouldn't think that it makes sense
to say we're going to go and we're going
to fix everything and we're going to do
it by dumping you know 100 100 billion
dollars on you and then if it doesn't
work out in 10 years we're leaving
we've got an exit strategy and then
we'll blame you we'll say you're all
cowardly and incompetent and corrupt and
we're off right
of course the
partnering is a very long patient
process and
part of the thing we did is that afghans
became frustrated because
we pretended to do things we couldn't do
instead of being honest from the
beginning
that it was going to be messy that it
was going to be very long term
and getting out and i think also was
wonderful on this the
the ridiculous you know hero to villain
thing that we did with the presidents
with president karzai and president
ghani
actually in many ways compared to
presidents and much of the rest of the
developing world these were pretty good
guys
the problem was that we would convince
ourselves one moment that they were
geniuses and saints and then the next
moment we all said that they were
corrupt and incompetent
it's a crazy way of thinking about
anything
really powerful lessons being shared
here um we have some questions coming in
and many of these questions are geared
toward afghanistan's future so i want to
make sure we move in that direction um
but first you know some of this has been
brought up
a crisis in terms of food security
hunger um but
as we all know
three months now into taliban rule the
country is really facing a humanitarian
crisis from its economy
to issues
related to hunger um i just want to hear
from each of you sort of what are your
top concerns when it comes to the state
of the country now and that will help us
transition into the role the
international development community
can and should play and perhaps what
they should stop doing um so uh as was
mentioned earlier before the taliban
takeover the country received an
enormous amount of foreign aid um or
zala mentioned earlier this problem of
of donor dependency um so perhaps that's
something we can bring into the
conversation as well like
how did the country end up here and it's
not just um the very messy withdrawal
that is part of it but there are other
dynamics at play as well so um what are
your top concerns uh in terms of the
crisis the country's facing now and then
we'll get into what the international
development community can do maybe we'll
start with holland
yeah absolutely
so just to put it in context afghanistan
received 40 percent of
compared to 40 percent of the gdp and
and aid
50 of the government's
budget was financed by donors
and that meant you know in a budget
where 75 percent of the
budget goes to operating you know
salaries of police and teachers and
civil servants you know half of it was
by by donors and everything the same
amount was off budget you know so eight
billion dollars suddenly it's like a tap
turned off overnight it's going
to create a massive problem it and it
already has and on top of it you have a
banking sector that you rely more and
more not for lending normal banking
because we had issues in that area but
but for transfers
so the meager savings that people had
equivalent to a few hundred dollars were
stuck in banks that they could not
uh
access for four weeks it created a
massive problem massive problem in urban
centers which was already
seeing higher levels of poverty levels
than than
than rural
sectors because they were dependent more
on on the government and other so my
biggest concern is that
the famine when in june and july i was
still at the government we launched a
humanitarian appeal with with a joint
one with the u.n because we were facing
problems with drought problems with
displacement and problems with covert
the third wave of covert was
very harsh and it had meant that uh 12
to 18 million people
half of the population then were at the
risk of it and now if you
add on top of it this sudden
reduction or stoppage of of it it's a
it's a huge catastrophe my biggest
concern is is that
i don't see unfortunately the urgency
from
international organizations everybody is
looking to the u.s treasury and u.s
treasury does not either care or
answer or they are afraid of biden
because he does not want to hear
afghanistan's name to put it very
bluntly
and
other international organizations
because they have powerful governors of
of the u.s government sitting on their
boards they are all paralyzed you know
the world bank sits on the biggest trust
fund in the world for afghanistan
afghanistan reconstruction trust fund
you have to just convert the ordinary
construction into relief and you know
re reprogram some of them but it's not
happening my concern is taking time on
this when we are approaching the winter
is is going to
cause massive
human suffering
maybe something that we haven't seen
at least not this century maybe in the
last 40 50 years uh 30 35
million people where uni is projecting
97 percent poverty
by the end of this year it's unheard of
anywhere and you know somebody who's
worked in this field i can tell you that
these are not exaggerated numbers right
97 percent could be
could be
you know the base case it could get get
worse worse than this
i think
humanitarian aid needs to move fast i i
think the international community
international donors
the un and the ifis who've been engaged
in afghanistan who've partnered have to
find a
a way
around the u.s tragedy
sanctions because those are not going to
be left at any time you know if you are
a realist
you have to think that but there are
other ways mechanisms through swapping
and
mechanisms through physical
transfer of cash into the country to
make sure that these programs
go ahead and talking of the gains some
of these
achievements that were made in
afghanistan were done and and in
collaboration with international
agencies but also ngos like the basic
package of health services
was all delivered through ngos this
community development councils by the uh
sub-national levels you know they could
you don't need to go through a taliban
administration
a u.n agency for example who could take
over the
coordination and invoicing and
messaging oversight mechanisms that was
done by ministry of public health and
you could still
still do this so
my concern is humanitarian plus
humanitarian plus i mean basic services
of health and education and community
development must flow otherwise
we will have uh
suffering at the large scale i think
just my last point something that uh
rory alluded to in his opening points
you also have to understand taliban
leverages like this do not work on them
you are creating suffering for a lot of
people they don't care about it you know
they could still rule with an iron fist
for the next 20 years and
there is a limit to how much aid
could have a
role you know so please have
look at my appeal to international
community is
look at the bigger picture look at the
suffering of a lot of people
and it's not just afghanistan it's going
to haunt the whole the whole world and
afghanistan
fortunately our unfortunate team will
always be in headlines you know if you
leave it like they have right now they
think it's the end of it it's not it's
going to come back and bite
everyone
so many great points and a couple things
i want to return to in a moment but i
want to bring uh dr ozala in here but um
you mentioned it was like turning the
tap off overnight and as you said it's
not just the foreign aid dollars but the
ngos working on the ground many of whom
have pulled out their staff are still
trying to figure out how to engage
one of the things i also appreciate
how that in addition to just outlining
the crisis and the urgency
you mentioned that there are practical
challenges but also ways to
um
find a way around sanctions and i do
hope we can kind of get into quite
practically how does the international
development community engage but first
um dr rosala i know you wanted to jump
in just in terms of outlining where the
country is now and then we'll kind of
move into where where things are headed
um just to to add in terms of you know
humanitarian crises um the the urgency
is is critical as we mentioned it
throughout the conversation here
but uh i like the point uh holland made
regarding you know humanitarian class
because
the goal here should not be to keep
afghanistan
we we have a a saying in afghanistan
that serum you know that you go you get
allergy the doctor immediately they put
us an injection in a serum to you we
don't want our country 38 million of
people
to become you know dependent on the aid
in food
so yes
feed people now because a a terrible
winter is on its way and people don't
have enough to keep themselves warm to
keep their children and themselves fed
so this is immediate emergency and i
call not only on donors and
organizations and government but also on
individuals anyone who knows someone in
afghanistan just should all you need is
a bank account and an id from someone
transfer some dollars transfer your
lunch money just be on a diet for one
day and get something send something
there because really everyone needs it
even people i'm telling this to the
middle class type of people even people
who had savings they saved a lot of
money for the future of their children
like you all will do the audience of
this panel
it's all frozen in the accounts they
cannot take it out so
this is a kind of a human responsibility
to all of us the issue is that this
should not be a long-term solution
the development assistance the
sustainability
of getting people afghan people are
entrepreneurs by nature
all they need is some means so
that should be really also critical to
tpm you know the development assistance
the development aid the development of
the economic development specifically is
something that we have to think about
longer term
later probably come in a moment on the
on the sanctions but stop the effects
yeah we'll return to that absolutely and
and that kind of the point you just made
kind of gets back to what rory was
saying in terms of small and medium
enterprises smes but rory did you want
to jump in
i think the first thing is that i think
all of us agree that
the international community should be
generous towards afghanistan now
that means getting humanitarian
assistance and now but it also means
continuing development assistance
right
not just emergency food aid but the
things that help the afghan economy grow
and help the afghan economy support
itself
why is it not happening
it's not happening for a series of
reasons one of them unfortunately is
there is a sense of emotional anger and
humiliation from the international
community
so when i say on twitter for example
please support afghanistan i get people
tweeting back saying
nonsense stuff like they chose the
taliban it's their fault why should we
help them now
so we have to be honest with people
about the fact that they're wrong in
saying that afghans chose the taliban
the other thing is that people believe
or are trying to convince themselves
particularly politicians that somehow
this is going to give people leverage
for the taliban well this is again wrong
it's wrong in many ways
as hamlet pointed out it just doesn't
work
many of these taliban fighters have been
living in very tough conditions in
refugee camps or
almost in caves in the hills in some
situation they're not like russian
oligarchs they don't want to go shopping
in
fifth avenue in manhattan right so
they're not primarily motivated by these
questions around sanctions but there's a
bigger point
which is that actually it's morally
wrong
to starve the afghan people believing
that by threatening to starve the afghan
people you're going to somehow get
political concessions out of the taliban
is
totally
immoral now what does this mean
practically
practically a lot of this is
bureaucratic this is
why is the money stopping it's stopping
often for small bureaucratic reasons
state department
has suddenly cancelled a lot of its
projects because they say they don't
have enough stuff on the ground to
administer them
the european union has cancelled a lot
of projects saying we don't do
development anymore we're now just going
to do humanitarian
usaid is trying to re-profile
right which is a very complicated
bureaucratic process where they're
saying we don't want to support export
industries like the carbon industry but
we're going to go into librarians
and then other people are saying no
there are terrorists who are in the
afghan government
and that's the most dangerous thing of
all because people are beginning to say
no but
this is sanctions people
let's say you export a carpet let's say
you pay two percent export tax and that
export tax goes to the afghan government
and the afghan government is the taliban
government and one of the ministers is a
terrorist are you funding terrorists
if you buy petrol
in the gas station
and you pay sales tax and that money
goes to the afghan government and the
afghan government is the taliban
government and a member of the cabinet's
terrorists are you funding terrorism so
the international community needs to be
clear and practical and take a little
bit of risk and make some decisions and
the decision has to be be quick
be generous and don't get caught up in
these
problems around sanctions
thank you rory we have a lot of
questions coming in from the audience
but first i wanted to see if orzala or
khaled wanted to respond to that at all
otherwise i definitely have some
questions to turn to
go ahead rosella
i just wanted to very briefly reiterate
on on the sanction point that rory has
made and then we can go to questions my
my personal view on the sanctions
situation is that i would like to know
about a country where sanctions have
achieved the goal that the country is
trying to punish economically those
countries have achieved and then i would
say yes this is the best solution i mean
emotions aside everyone is angry and
absent in one way or another but here
it's not about me and what i lost it's
about 30 million people
six million of whom are living in kabul
one of the most highly population
concentrated uh
cities in the country and they just
don't know what to do next the urban
poverty is as much deep and as much
dangerous as the rural poverty the rural
is a little bit less at risk at this
time because they have been like going
through this poverty for long long time
but even people with as i said small and
medium set of activities and enterprises
are are going into crisis so
the question has there has to be a
distinction between
giving legitimacy to some actions that a
taliban government
are taking
particularly their gender appetites at
the moment in terms of you know complete
discrimination against women they have
to really and and just to share with you
i mean some some sort of reflections
from the ground
within the taliban within the taliban
younger generation forces
they themselves are not convinced and
i'm sure they're listening to me saying
that they are not convinced with these
actions of closing girls education
because i am sure their own sisters at
home are not happy with this decision if
their sisters are living in in
afghanistan at the moment which i'm sure
for some of them it's the case if
they're in the middle of their
universities they cannot attend the
universities they are also not confident
and they are already like somebody was
sharing on social media a picture of uh
drive-through which shows girls going to
school and immediately one of the young
taliban tweeted and arabic and says this
is rumors against the taliban that girls
are not letting to go to school here
look they are going to school and that
guy again corrected himself says no this
is primary school these are not children
these are not secondary in high school
and university students girls are still
not going
so scholars islamic scholars from around
the world called on taliban and says can
you come into a conversation with us so
that we can resolve this
my view is that
the issue of girls education is not
related to international lobbying and
advocacy i think the people of
afghanistan themselves will manage their
way to convince taliban to to
move on from this very
um and logical sort of step to to keep
girls away from education and to keep
women away from work practically sector
by sector that we see
we observe some flexibility
health sector was first they never had
restrictions on doctors attending the
clinics or nurses but slowly vaccination
slowly added so there has to be ongoing
engagement dehumanization
has not worked will not work so there
has to be ongoing engagement
sanctions from the global from
international point of view is
completely problematic as an afghan
i think it's extremely problematic in it
the harm of it will go to the average
african living in zabal orozcon
everywhere in the country
or hazard everywhere basically
it will not affect the taliban it will
not because
let's not forget the role of illicit
economy in the country
other secondary sources that are not on
the record but still feed very well this
kind of government and systems and those
in power
or zala i want to bring in one question
from the audience for you and you may
have just touched on this but in case
there's anything to add the question is
what is your outlook regarding women and
girls under the taliban what is your
biggest concern and any ideas for
solutions
uh my outlook uh despite
going through a very very harsh
situation at the moment in terms of you
know women and girls education and i
have like hundreds of women and girls
basically
contacting me and i'm sure many other
women leaders and what will be the next
i'm personally optimistic that this will
be very temporary and there will be
changes and pressure on taliban
uh i'm not necessarily talking only
about international international
pressure should also be consistent but
national pressure is consistent on
taliban to come into terms in terms of
allowing education allowing women to
work in in different sectors and even
allowing women to work also in politics
so
the concern the biggest concern is to
just
see some countries major countries with
a lot of leverages and influences try to
just keep a close eye on all the actions
of the taliban at national level and
just move on by legitimizing them so
there is a very narrow
sort of line here not not to be crossed
engage yes but not legitimize their
actions so that they don't get
overconfident by some of the wrongdoings
that they do in terms of you know moving
forward
so continuous engagement is is key to
move forward
concern is to see this falling down
afghanistan should remain in
conversations but in a constructive
constructive conversations not really
something that will continue to divide
us and rule us
thank you so speaking of um this concern
of legitimizing there's a question here
um kind of broadening the lens in terms
of the international community's future
engagement with afghanistan here's a
question from our audience building on
some of what's been discussed but just
presenting another opportunity to
revisit this so the question is i think
the appetite for doing more development
in afghanistan is constrained not by the
view that we failed in afghanistan but
by the argument that offering
development aid will legitimize the
taliban government or prop them up in
some way
she goes on to say development aid is
never neutral so how do we do it
ethically in this context without being
seen to or actually propping up the
taliban government
rory
well there's no easy answers to this and
we need to be realistic about this i
mean we can produce spin and obviously
the principle needs to be to try to make
sure that the development in
humanitarian aid
reaches ordinary afghans and doesn't
reach the taliban government but as i've
tried to explain nothing is ever quite
that simple because if an ngo fills up
their car at a gas station
they will pay sales tax on that and some
of that will go to the taliban
government and that is
unfortunately true not just in
afghanistan it's true if you're doing
humanitarian aid in south sudan it's
true if you're doing humanitarian
development aid almost anywhere around
the world you have to make difficult
compromises with the government
the leverage though that we should be
exercising over the taliban government
is around diplomatic recognition
and maybe you could say to them look
we're going to provide
a generous level of humanitarian and
development support to the afghan people
but if you want more than that if you
want diplomatic recognition if you want
more evidence opportunities these are
the things you have to do
but don't use
as i keep saying starving people
as a way of trying to threaten the
taliban government
it's not going to work they're not going
to pay any attention it hasn't worked
anywhere in the world
it's a very very mad thing to do and
remember
above all what that will mean is if you
do this
if the taliban government
finally goes
in 20 years time
afghans will be very very rightly angry
with the international community if you
want to have a good relationship with
afghanistan you're not going to achieve
it by starving the people and pretending
that by doing so you're going to change
the behavior of the taliban
thanks rory and building on that
question there's another question here
that i'd love for khalid to jump in um
and answer and the question is are there
practical ways the west can engage with
the taliban
without invoking feelings of negotiating
with terrorists so kind of building on
what um what rory just responded to but
um khaled i think you could respond to
this specifically
i
completely second rory on this this
part as well but as as he said there are
no easy straightforward answers but
what's the alternative the alternative
of shutting
them off and doing no engagement you
don't use any of the leverages that you
have you know so
then you also play into the hands of the
hardliners within taliban and they would
say you know these
westerners these infidels you know you
they're never straight and
look what they've done
they would you are providing a breeding
ground for future generations of
terrorists or even people who are angry
angry at the west of being betrayed
uh and and left alone so uh i think
engagement
on uh
humanitarian plus should be a gateway
for for further discussions i think
they've they've shown some willingness
on discussions on on girls education for
example which is
which is a
welcome
[Music]
improvement in development but but more
should be done but still
um
i believe if there is the issue of
going through the taliban government and
then financing going through them as a
concern there are ways as i said earlier
you know you have national programs for
example the citizen charter or national
basic package of health services you
just have to replace the
government agency that used to do the
oversight with another
agency or probably you and us is
engaging uh
through them so that that's a that's a
start and
uh
taliban would want sustainability of
their rule uh a very angry population is
not uh not very conducive for that so
they understand that
but then there is a limit to all of this
would at what cost are we going to
isolate taliban
at the cost of
30 million people starving to death
i think it's it's not going to go
look good on the whole
western idea of uh freedom and
and human rights
so
you have to engage with them and
and as uh rory and ursula have mentioned
we don't have to go far to to see for an
example of how isolation has not worked
you know look at our neighboring iran in
the last 40 years crippling
sanctions you know for people who've
been there you know hyperinflation but
what has happened they've
increased in
their grasp and
on the system and population more
i think
abandoning discussions with the taliban
might not be the right approach
one other question i'd love to just
squeeze in from the audience before
coming to each of you with final
thoughts
we've been talking about a lot about the
west and interactions of afghanistan
moving forward and there's a question
about regional politics neighboring
countries and larger powers like china
and russia so i wonder if anyone would
want to jump in on that question
maybe i could uh
add a couple of points before rory and
orzella
have their views
i think
we have to study every
neighbor you know
pakistan has won this it's something
that we haven't recognized enough as
this is a
pakistan enabled invasion you know
regardless of what issues we had in the
government we had an elected government
a democracy that was
improving uh it's it's better than
what's happening
right now you know so
they did not want an indian influence
and they've got it i don't think they
want a stable fully stable afghanistan
either the status quo is the ideal
situation for for for
isi and and pakistan to have an
afghanistan you know you you have as
long as it's contained uh people who
have a longer view in pakistan are
worried and they've they're worried that
this
fanaticism will spill over their borders
and it already has
what what
russia it was a difficult uh
uh
situation they wanted u.s out of the
region but they also don't want
the
extremism crossing the amu river into
the
central asian
countries
with with china you know
i i believe
as long as it gets contained in
afghanistan they have access to the
minerals and
lithium and copper and all that's uh
that's a one for them and and
uh
for iran as well you know i think
they wanted
u.s
losing in afghanistan
but they want stable right now they want
stable borders so they could dump their
low quality fuel and other products that
they cannot do anywhere else because of
the sanctions
whether pakistan and others as long as
they have borders and
exports and that's contained in
afghanistan that's fine you know so
i in a summary not a lot of the mind the
current situation as long as it's in
afghanistan and does not create bigger
headaches
but that view might be a short-term view
the long-term uh and unstable
afghanistan at the heart of asia is not
good for the whole
region but also the whole world
thank you holland uh rory did you want
to jump in on that quickly okay just uh
no no i'll leave you because you you're
heading towards the end aren't you you
want to do some final cut
yeah if you don't mind um we do just
have a couple minutes left so maybe
anything you want to note on that we can
get to but um i just want to as we close
we've covered so much ground and
again our task today was certainly to
look at how we got here um the state of
the country currently but particularly
afghanistan's future um and so i wonder
just in our last couple minutes here and
i hate to ask such a big question with
only about 30 seconds left for each of
you but um
you know you've all made so many great
points what's one thing you want to
leave our audience with
in terms of afghanistan's future a call
to action specifically for the
international development community
which we've discussed quite a bit um
maybe we'll
start with you orzala and then we'll
hear from khalid and we'll close with
rory
thank you catherine um i hope to be able
to say it in 30 seconds but
my personal message to the international
development
aide and to to to those who are willing
to support and sponsor is to invest on
the afghanistan's young generation
provide them with scholarship
opportunities
now before it becomes too late
particularly girls
i am working on a personal mission on
this together with another yale world
fellow uh as we are at yale university i
will say this lord nosolis she's also a
world fellow and i'm hoping to get your
support
uh for this mission uh starting with a
small group of young afghan girls and
expanding it to larger one the best way
forward
in the longer term is to invest on young
generation scholarships across different
themes and subjects not only social or
political sciences but
very critical subjects for the future of
the country thank you
thank you helen
yeah i
i think act now before six to nine
months or even three to six months of
weight would might be too late
uh
but for for my fellow afghans you know
somebody who's
who's seen it somebody has been part of
this government that has collapsed
somebody who
shares parts of the blame you know
i am a big critic of of myself as well i
think it's
all hope is not lost
we should use this to examine the
the things that went wrong
if we have a better uh opportunity in
the future what sort of democracy would
be built something that's built in the
matter of the west and
copies it or let's is there some
modifications that we would want to do
um i think the international community
on development aid should also
have lessons you know there were so many
nitty
uh
and details on aid
that that could have made better impact
in the lives of people i hope those
lessons are are learned and when we
intervene in afghanistan or re-entertain
or somewhere else we we
we make better use of the tax dollars
and that are paid
thank you rory
well i think my final thing is be
generous be quick have hope and remember
that when you're talking about hope
you're having hope in afghans themselves
and i think dr orson and hallelujah have
been an extraordinary illustration of
why the international community should
be hopeful about afghanistan we've had
two individuals speaking whose
adult lives really have been dominated
by the last 20 years and what you're
seeing in
what you've just witnessed is
remember
both doctors around holland have been
through incredible trauma their family
their friends
their entire lives have been turned
upside down and yet you can see they are
talking with incredible grace humility
thoughtfulness
objectivity they're not putting their
own self-interest forward they're trying
to frame
constructive positive solutions in an
unbelievably difficult situation
and so that should really give us hope
because that is of course what people
like me love about afghanistan that's
why the international community should
believe in the future of afghanistan
i love that if we were all together in
person i know the audience would be
applauding um and i would as well so
thank you so much to our panelists for
this conversation on afghanistan's
future
uh again this conversation was part of a
larger series the yell development
dialogues which will be continuing so
stay tuned and thanks so much to our
audience for tuning in we'll see you
next time